Rebecca Brooks married a nice tender and
then a country gent encountered Prime
Minister's as friends and confidants
regardless of political persuasion even
royal princes got Rebecca but it's her
relationship with another man that saw
her rise to being the most powerful
woman in British media and a paid-up
member of the Chipping Norton set a
clique of the rich and famous with bolt
holes nestled in the Cotswolds
countryside it was at her wedding
reception here at this Country Estate
just down the road from chipping norton
well you got a real glimpse into the
extent of the power and influence
wielded by Rebecca Brooks the sheer
number of friends in high places on the
guest list there were two prime
ministers a fair chunk of the Murdoch
client including Rupert himself who flew
in especially for it
a handful of captains of industry and
around 200 other movers and shakers but
it wasn't always like this for Rebecca
Brooks it was 1988 when Fleet Street
veteran Charlie ray set a young green 20
year old Rebecca Wade as she was then on
her way in national newspapers she was a
very young naive girl who came into the
office clearly had ambition clearly was
intelligent and had said I want to be a
journalist now my job if you like in
that case as well point you in a
direction I can't do these sort of
things for so she was I liked her you
know I liked to write at the start
she was quite fun within weeks miss Wade
had a job at the news of the world six
years later she was deputy editor at
thirty-one she was the boss Rupert
Murdoch had decided his tabloids needed
a fresh approach Rebecca weighed her
soon to be deputy and lover Andy Coulson
and another young editor Piers Morgan
was seen as the future they were the
bright yellow things of Fleet Street and
was seen to be that they came through at
a time I think where there was a
deliberate decision to try to change the
direction and the move
of how those papers operated that's the
son that news the world and of course
the Daily Mirror which is where piers
ended up and it was a conscious decision
by Rupert Murdoch then he wanted change
Rebecca Brooks and Andy Coulson may have
shared a newsroom a dock at the Old
Bailey and as we now know Abed but they
were very different editors lands price
was one of Tony Blair's spin-doctors
when he was Prime Minister and mrs.
Brooks was a regular visitor Rebecca
Brooks has always been one of the very
best networkers in that world of
politics and media whether two combined
she's always kept close to prime
ministers of whatever party they were I
work for a Labour Prime Minister she was
in and out of Downing Street all the
time and she was good enough at her job
to have the same sort of relationship
with David Cameron when he became a
conservative Prime Minister Andy Coulson
spent even more time at Downing Street
giving old Etonian David Cameron the
common touch he needed to run the
country Andy Coulson came from a council
house if you talk to people in politics
even now they will say that to this day
forget the phone hacking
Cameron misses Andy Coulson's
understanding of real people who are
outside of Cameron's world but it was
phone hacking that brought both Coulson
and Brooks down and ultimately closed
the newspaper they both edited and which
was owned and run by the man who used to
treat Rebecca as a fifth daughter part
of the family with her acquittal at the
Old Bailey will he now bring her back
into the family business
Debbie bogan Sky News